This is part two of exposing Ottery Noah as a content thief.
Last time we spoke, I outlined two creators Ottery Noah stole
from in a short 4-minute video. Ottery Noah was stealing other
people's assets and scripts, then remixing them as his own. >> Vasquez
starts the shot as an amorphous blob before the AI starts to
put a mouth on her cheek. >> In this shot here with Vasquez,
it tries to read her face at first as an amorphous blob because
it doesn't recognize her face is a face. In one of his videos,
he even took beat for beat from another creator, Vincent Pavarell.
>> Then there's still The Accountant 2 and Drop. Both wellreceived.
>> You could have gone to see The Accountant Too. >> Tron
Aries did not have girl boss in the >> Tron Aries didn't
contain a girl boss at >> I'm not saying Greta Ali's character
was well written, but not once in the movie did she ever belittle
the male characters around her. >> Eve Kim may have not
been the most compelling character ever, but she wasn't a girl
bos. She literally spends a good chunk of the ending being trapped
and eventually saved by Aries. >> She spent most of the
movie being trapped and had to be rescued by Aries at the very
end. In fact, >> the same day I released my video, Otto
Noah did a live stream where he was confronted for stealing from
a total of four creators, Shamu, Nicandros, Vincent Pavarell,
and Nurell. >> I think this is probably a pretty fair resolution.
And then you've conceded on the Shimu stuff, the Dandra stuff,
and the Shimu allegations and the two other examples we brought
to your attention. >> Yeah, sure. That's That's completely
valid. Um >> Mhm. And what are you going to do moving forward
if you're using other creators? >> I am happy to credit
them. I think I think we learned that per day early on in the
stream, but I'm happy to credit
>> All right. That's valid. That's valid. >> That's
That's very valid. That's That's very valid as well. That's very
valid. Very valid. >> And this is where we run into problems.
It seems Audly Noah's takeaway from my video and that stream
was that he needed to site his works better. And while it's true
he does need to site when he uses other people's graphics or
parts of their research, the bigger allegation was him stealing
scripts and lifting videos beat for beat. Probably aware I was
recently accused of plagiarizing in three separate videos.
>> These videos did not have their sources cited correctly.
I absolutely made a mistake and I want to apologize and I will
cite every single video source properly in my videos going forward.
He conveniently leaves out the fact that he stole both the graphics
and script from Vincent Pavarell and Nurell. No citation would
fix this issue unless he had permission from the original creators,
which he did not. Later in this response video, his first idea
for fixing things was to use a plagiarism bot to check all of
his scripts for plagiarism. Once a script is completed for its
first draft, I will also be running it through various plagiarism
detection software that people have suggested I look at. The
one that I have personally chosen to go with based on what I
was suggested is Paperowl, which is a free online textbased plagiarism
detector. I'm hoping by using this website with my scripts going
forward. Nothing I say in any of my videos will even unintentionally
be plagiarism. And if there is anything I need to site in a video,
this will tell me. Now, why would Noah need a plagiarism bot
to check his work when he is the plagiarist and he's the one
stealing content? It's very clear Noah is trying to only get
away with owning up to having poor citation. Nowhere in his follow-up
video does he own up to stealing content. Now, week or two has
passed. I haven't thought much of it until about today. I decided
to go through Noah's videos again. Wouldn't you know it, the
very next video I decided to scan through, I found Ottery Noah
stealing someone else's script beat for beat and remixing it
for himself. The original work was a video called Jester Bell's
delusional Supergirl Rant by Sergey Kravana. Ottery Noah put
the plagiarism in his video anti-woke hate for Supergirl is laughably
petty. So, let's take a look at the evidence. >> So, the
Supergirl trailer had a variety of reactions, and this was one
of them I was suggested to respond to. >> Recently, she
did a video about Supergirl as well. So, let's see what she had
to say. >> Now, it gets a lot worse, so hang on. But right
out the gate, Ottoy Noah steals the exact same screenshot from
Sergey. It's the same size and the same >> Hello everyone.
Female Froto Baggins here. And can you guess my reaction to the
latest Supergirl trailer? Hello everyone,
female Froto Baggins here. And can you guess my reaction to the
latest Supergirl trailer? >> Okay, but this is a trailer,
not a >> And funny enough, now Jester Bell is doing the
exact same thing, talking about the trailer for Supergirl before
the movie's even out. I don't know why so many people on YouTube
seem to think that they're time travelers all of a >> I
guess Jester DL must have magically found a Delorean or something
though and traveled to 2026. >> This is a James Gun movie.
It is James Gun through and through in the same way that all
movies that come from Marvel are essentially just Kevin Feige
projects. James Gun is just hiring yesmen to make his project.
This is a James Gun movie. It is James Gun through and through.
In the same way that all movies that come from Marvel are essentially
just Kevin Feige projects. James Gun is just hiring Yesmen to
make his projects. >> Iron Man is a completely different
movie from Winter Soldier. The Avengers is a completely different
movie from Guardians of the Galaxy. >> Iron Man 3 feels
like a very different movie than Thor. Spider-Man Homecoming
feels like a very different movie than Black Panther. The Avengers
is a very different movie than Guardians of the Galaxy. So, they
put out this poster and this little um uh gift the other day
advertising the teaser trailer and the poster says truth, justice,
whatever.
Wow. So edgy. So edgy, James, you really really got that edge
there. So they put out this poster and this little um gift the
other day advertising the teaser trailer and the poster says
truth, justice, whatever.
Wow. So edgy. So edgy, James. You really, really got that edge
there. >> It's almost as if they're using a variation to
contrast Superman's character. Jester Bell also doesn't seem
to understand. This slogan is supposed to show the contrast in
the ideals of Supergirl and Superman. >> Are character
flaws bad to establish. >> this slogan is supposed to show
some of her character flaws, like her being a bit more reckless
than Superman himself. Because if she didn't have any character
flaws, I'm betting people would go on about how she's a Mary
Sue. says, "If the trailer showed that she didn't have any character
flaws, then this crowd would just go the other direction and
call her a Mary Sue." >> And and and I'm getting ahead
of myself a little bit. In the trailer, she says, you know, he
believes in the good of people and she believes in the truth,
which is all all people are just terrible at stuff like that.
And and and I'm getting ahead of myself a little bit. In the
trailer, she says, you know, he believes in the good of people
and she believes in the truth, which is all all people are just
terrible at stuff like that. >> That's not the same statement.
And I have no clue how you arrived at that >> No, that's
not really what was said there whatsoever. Jester Bell seems
to have completely jumped to conclusions here and failed to realize
that's not really what that quote is saying at all. James Gun's
Superman felt like he did not want to make the movie. He didn't
want to do Superman. And I will never forget that quote before
he signed on to it that said that Superman was not a character
that enticed him. Krypto was what he finally got to get himself
to to work on the project because that's what they wanted him
to do. James Gun Superman felt like he did not want to make the
movie. He didn't want want to do Superman. And I will never forget
that quote before he signed on to it that said that Superman
was not a character that enticed him. Krypto was what he finally
got to get himself to to work on the project cuz that's what
they wanted him to do. >> James Gunn initially wasn't ready
to commit to Superman because he was still feeling the trauma
of his Marvel firing. >> What was going on at the time
was him feeling the trauma of being fired by Disney for his old
tweets. His ideas for the Suicide Squad simply arrived to him
>> and he ended up going to work on the Suicide Squad at
the time instead. >> Noah's video is nearly 50 minutes.
I only analyzed about 6 minutes of the video. I don't really
have time to continue to prove the same point over and over,
but I assure you I did find more. It's clear Noah runs someone
else's script through chat GPT, scrambles it, and sometimes it's
easy to find the plagiarism, but sometimes it's more difficult,
but you can tell there is some overlap. What I would ask of Noah
is one, if I looked at three videos and found three plagiarized
works, how much of your catalog is stolen? Two, you still haven't
taken down the other video you stole from. Will you take it down
in any other videos you've taken beat forbeat? And three, why
should your audience trust any future apology when the last one
was meaningless? That's it for today. As always, thanks for